- This next story just made headlines.
And when I thought I wanted to talk
to her so bad,
local news anchor Lena Pringle
from Florida became the story herself.
She posted a photo of
her new short haircut
and it went viral
and here to tell us why
that is so important
is Lena Pringle herself.
(crowd applauding)
- Hi.
- Hi Lena.
Thank you so much--
- Hi, good morning.
- Good morning.
Thank you so much for coming on this show.
This story is really important
and you were experiencing
pressure in the workplace
and you posted this photo
and it went bananas
and will you please just
tell me everything about it?
- [Lena Pringle] Yes so the caption is,
a shout out to the people who told me
I wouldn't be able to get
or keep a broadcast news job
with a short natural haircut.
Jokes on you, huh?
With a few cute emojis.
A few weeks ago,
I just haven't been in
the best mental state.
I have been depressed.
I've been in a rut.
I've just not been completely there.
My friend actually sent me
a picture of this haircut
and my hair has already been short,
so, you know, I was like,
why not try something different?
Cause when you look good, you feel good.
I was really just looking for
a morale booster to get
out of such a low time.
And so, I went to my hairdresser,
she hooked me up,
shout out to Keisha,
she did great here in Jacksonville.
I took these pictures because I felt good,
I looked good
and I said, you know what,
let me just post this.
I post pictures all the time,
so this isn't anything new.
Now the attention definitely is.
- And it's been retweeted
over 10,000 times
with a ton of positive responses.
- Yeah.
I just can't believe it.
Something that was
literally done as a way to
boost my morale.
I'm a huge mental health advocate.
So something that was so simple
in nature to me that has
gained so much attention
and encouragement
and support.
I am just, honestly, it's still...
I'm in awe.
I just can't believe
the outreach from people.
I'm hearing from girls in high school,
to a women with PhDs,
to men
and barbers
and all types of people who are just
showing their genuine love
and support for authenticity
and I just can't--
- Oh, I'm so sorry.
No, I'm so sorry.
- Oh no, you go ahead.
- One of the things that
I really love about this,
is the risk that you took.
This wasn't just,
empowerment and bravery.
You have high stakes at work
and a Dove study found
that black women are like
80% more likely to
change their natural hair
to meet expectations in the workplace
and Deb has been leading
this chart with the crown act
and in fact,
yesterday ,
it's announced that they
passed at least in the house
a bill
which is one step forward
to not having hair race-based
work discrimination.
So I think what you did
is really important for this movement
and Dove even retweeted your photo.
(crowd applauding)
- Yeah Dove and the Crown Act.
I think it's so amazing because in 2020,
there literally has to be a law passed
nationwide
to prohibit discrimination
against natural hair.
Simply the way our hair grows
out of our head,
there has to be a law that's passed
just so we're able to
not be discriminated against.
And you know it's crazy because last year
when the Crown Act passed in California,
it was a huge landmark decision
but at that point there
was only a few States
that were behind it.
So now to see this pass in
the house and move forward,
I know for me
and several other black women
in this industry particularly,
I'm in an industry that's built upon looks
and aesthetics,
we stand...
This charge has been happening
for the past 15 to 20 years.
There have been women that have been
knocking down the barriers
that have been saying, you know what?
You will accept me.
I am going to take up this space.
So I think it's a
beautiful moment right now
because you're seeing more
black women on air with natural hair,
locks,
braids,
literally taking up all the space
and just being who they are.
- Wow.
- And it's a beautiful thing
because we stand on the
shoulders of the women
that have been knocking down the door
so that we're able to do this.
- And I thank you
for everything that you are doing
and that's why we wanted to
celebrate you here today.
And thank you for being here
and sharing this story and
breaking this news with us.
And thank you, Lena.
(upbeat music)